SCP-682 Vs a Vacuum.
And we’re not talking about the household
cleaning appliance.
Could the Hard to Destroy Reptile survive
in a completely air-free environment?
To find out, 99% of the oxygen was removed
from a testing chamber that SCP-682 was trapped
inside.
The creature entered a dormant state, and
began producing what the Foundation believed
to be its native atmosphere - A mixture of
56% ozone, 23% chlorine, 18% xenon, and other
caustic elements.
The test was eventually called to an end,
however, when our normal earth atmosphere
was reintroduced into the room, it reacted
with the compound that 682 was releasing,
and caused a massive explosion that blew off
the blast door.
A scientist remarked that it was no wonder
682 was so hardy if that poisonous mix was
its native atmosphere.